la france vient de recevoir un nouvel
ordinateur contre date à 6600 de
fabrication américaine la plus grosse
machine intellectuelle du monde les df a
récemment acquis en appareils de ce type
mais celui ci est installée à la haye si
à la société d'informatique appliquée ce
ce qui était privé et spécialisé dans le
traitement de l'information
un tel appareil est trois à quatre fois
plus puissant que les caps ne recule at
her actuellement en service dans le
monde
il permettra de traiter plus
complètement des problèmes
le complexe on peut alimenter l'appareil
en informations sous forme de cartes
perforées qu'ils avalent dans ce
dispositif à raison de 1500 cartes à la
minute
la cia possédez déjà le frère aîné du
6600 le 3600 appareils de très grande
puissance pourtant mais qui ne suffit
plus quand on veut traiter les problèmes
très compliqués de gestion ou les
calculs scientifiques le cerveau de
l'ordinateur se compose d'éléments plus
simple des modules électroniques
c'est ici que se fait le calcul le
pupitre de commande du 6600 est plus
simple que celui du 3600 c'est moins
impressionnant à première vue mais cet
écran facilite le dialogue entre l'homme
et la machine
et voici l'ensemble de calcul du monstre
en une seconde il fait autant
d'opérations qu'un comptable durant
toute sa vie
3 à 4 millions il retrouve un mot dans
sa mémoire en 100 milliardièmes de
seconde le câblage est calculé en
fonction du temps que doivent mettre les
électrons pour le parcourir et c'est
pour cela qu'il est si compliqué sur cet
énorme disque véritable bibliothèque
magnétiques sont stockés 132 millions de
caractères
l'ordinateur a fait son travail
il fournit les résultats sous forme de
bandes imprimé à très grande vitesse
mais il peut faire mieux il peut
dessiner des courbes des schémas des
graphiques
regardez cette machine c'est celle qui
changera le plus notre vie dans l'avenir